هناك دائمًا الكثير من الضجيج حول
حدث تفاحة بالطبع
ويبدو أن هذا كله يتعلق بالسرعة
العالية ،
فهل من المقرر أن يكون دفعة مبيعات كبيرة
بشكل جيد ، فهذا يعتمد على الطريقة التي تنظر بها إلى
إكليل الجبل الذي يطلق عليه اسم
السرعة العالية وهذا هو  لأخذ تقنية 5g
وتحويلها إلى هواتف أسرع بكثير ،
فإن التحدي في الولايات المتحدة
والأسواق الأخرى حول العالم هو أن
5g لم تنتشر في
الشبكات حتى الآن ، لذا فهذه لعبة مبكرة
على الرغم من أن شركة آبل ليست مبكرة
للعبة
ولكن  ما يقومون بالاعتماد عليه هو 350 إلى
950 مليونًا
من مستخدمي Apple على هواتفهم ،
مستعدون لإعادة التدوير يطلقون عليها اسم
الدورة الفائقة لأبل في الوقت الحالي ،
لكنهم ليسوا متقدمين على المنحنى لأنني
أقترح أن يكون لديك موتورولا
google samsung huawei كلها مزودة
بشبكات 5g uh ، لكن هل لديك مدن مثل
شنغهاي أو
سيول قامت بالفعل ببناء هذه
الشبكات ، وهذا ليس هو الحال في
الولايات المتحدة في الواقع ،
فإن المشتركين الأمريكيين واحد في المائة فقط
يمتلكون هواتف 5g
و ca  n الاستفادة من تلك الشبكات التي من
المتوقع أن تبحث عن 74 75
بحلول عام 2025. لذا فإن ما تعول عليه شركة آبل الآن
هو
شاشة أكبر للطرز ربما
والولاء للتصميم
على الرغم من تأخرهم في دخول السوق
مع 5 جرام ، إلا أنه ليس وراء التكنولوجيا
في  الولايات المتحدة وهذا هو
السوق الرئيسية بالنسبة
لهم بالطبع